[Музика]
завтра шкіра ефективна
саме страх перед відправкою кожного італійського пан.
Прітчетт на заняттях Софія, чоловік, який голиться,
який, напевно, знає відео
[Музика]
привіт, хлопці, пора уроку англійської,
мене звуть Наталія, давайте давайте почнемо,
і у мене знову менше в класі так,
привіт, як я вам сьогодні винен, я я  почувай себе
добре добре
так і чекаєш цього уроку ти
схвильований я схвильований, тому що
подорожі це моє, це моє життя, це про
моє життя так
, скажімо, справжній експерт, тож ти
любиш подорожувати я впевнений, що ти любиш
давайте почнемо  урок, тому як домашнє завдання
я попросив вас скласти речення,
використовуючи я бачив транспортні засоби
в країні або я не бачив в
країні наприклад я бачив стрілу в
Україні або я не бачив гондолу в
Україна, скажімо, чи можете ви мені допомогти
з реченням так, звичайно,
то наведіть мені пару прикладів я
бачив пожежну машину в Україні добре я
бачив тролейбус у менісках добре я
бачив автобус у Білорусі добре я бачив
літак в Абу-Дабі  молодець я бачив,
що про я не бачив я не бачив
верблюд в Україні молодець добре
я не бачив трактор в Дубаї ти
коли-небудь бачив трактор в Дубаї молодець
так ні так я не бачив овець у
квартирі добре це дуже гарне
речення, а як щодо ваших речень
можете перевірити з нами, давайте йти далі, тому у мене
є завдання для вас,
подивіться на картинку, щоб
усі зображення змішалися, і ви можете
побачити колодязь, але тут є шість транспортних засобів,
ви можете вгадати менше ніж за п'ять секунд для
вас і  хлопці п'ять секунд для вас один
два три чотири п'ять так що ви бачите
я бачу верблюда як будь-який інструктор
тролейбус скутер
літак і гондола добре подивіться на мої
фотографії ви бачите літак тут хм
це не кривавий літак це що цей
підводний човен підводний човен підводний човен
добре, тож давайте переглянемо з вами слова
гондола гондола гондола верблюд верблюд
тролейбус тролейбус трактор трактор підводний
човен підводний човен скутер скутер молодці,
дякую, хлопці, то давайте сьогодні рухатися далі,
ми послухаємо діалог, добре, і у нас
є трохи PHR  я не знаю, що
ви там робили, це як пройшло ваше свято,
це номер два B, це звучить так, ніби
ви чудово провели час, це наступне,
яка була погода, і чи можу я побачити
їх, у нас є п'ять фраз, у нас є
діалог  з пробілами, які вам потрібно
додати до діалогу, прочитайте його, і у вас
є п’ять секунд, щоб виконати завдання, а
потім ми разом перевіримо тут, у
класі, так що один два три чотири п’ять,
що, на вашу думку, буде
уроком номер один  привіт, Емма, приємно вас бачити
,
нам потрібно використати фразу, але
подивіться на наступний приклад, це було чудово.
Дякую, ми поїхали в Лондон, як пройшли ваші
відпустки, як пройшли ваші відпустки, добре зробили
це було чудово, ми поїхали в Лондон, добре
наступного  один О,
мм-хм, було гарно і сонячно, яка
погода, яка була погода,
як була гарна та сонячна. Коричневий так,
наступний у нас є той, який ми
оглянули визначні пам'ятки та відвідали Лондонський зоопарк, це
було дивно, моєму маленькому брату дуже
сподобалося  яка на вашу думку
правильна відповідь
що ви там робили так, що ви
там робили, ми були молодці, тому ми
оглянули визначні пам'ятки та відвідали Лондонський зоопарк, це
було дивовижно,
і моєму брату дуже сподобалося, чи він
бачив левів,
о, так, довжина Левів була гіршою,
просто чудово, він  також воював з
пінгвінами та як змія. Вау,
це звучить так, ніби ти чудово провів час так,
правильна відповідь - добре, і
останній і останній я можу їх побачити
так Браво, я можу їх побачити,
впевнений, чому б тобі не зайти  до цієї
суботи у мене також є багато відео,
я хотів би зараз перевіряти, ми
збираємося прослухати діалог і прочитати його
ще раз,
так що благословенно, що це для вас, щоб зробити ваше
життя легшим, і ви готові читати разом з нами
читай і слухай діалог
привіт, Емма,
приємно бачити тебе, як пройшов твій відпочинок,
це було чудово, дякую, ми поїхали в Лондон О,
яка погода була гарна
та сонячна, що ви там робили,
ми оглянули визначні пам'ятки та відвідали Лондонський
зоопарк, це було дивно  моєму маленькому брату
дуже сподобалося, коли він побачив левів  о,
так, країна Левів була просто чудовою,
він також годував пінгвінів і тримав
змію, вау, це звучить так, ніби ви чудово провели
час,
так, це було просто ідеально, я зробив багато
фотографій, чи можу я побачити їх,
впевнений, чому б вам не зайти  цієї суботи у
мене також багато відео,
я хотів би молодці, зараз давайте прочитаємо
зі мною діалог я буду Енді,
а ти будеш Еммою, і
наступного разу ми будемо читати з  Ліза,
добре,
слухай, ти слухай, як я розмовляю зі
студентами, добре, скажи привіт, Емма,
приємно бачити тебе, як пройшли твоє свято, і
ти добре відповідаєш.
чудовий час, я б хотів їх побачити,
я хотів би зараз, ми збираємося читати
з Лізою, а ти слідкуй за нами, тож давайте подивимося,
ким би ти хотів бути Енді чи Еммою
я збираюся я буду Енді Енді добре,
тож ти  Енді, я Емма, давайте почнемо, Енді
починає, привіт, Емма, приємно бачити тебе, як пройшла
твоя відпустка,
це було чудово. Дякую, ми поїхали до Лондона.
d погода була гарна
та сонячна, що ви там робили, ми пішли
оглядати визначні пам'ятки та відвідали Лондонський зоопарк, це
було дивно,
моєму маленькому брату дуже сподобалося,
чи він бачив левів, о, так,
і з ліній було просто чудово, він також
нагодував  Пінгвіни та як змія Вау,
це звучить так, ніби ви чудово провели час, так,
це було просто ідеально, я зробив багато
фотографій, чи можу я їх побачити, чи
можу я побачити їх, чи точно, чому б вам не
зайти цієї суботи, у мене є багато відео
Я також хотів би дуже подякувати вам, тому
завдання для вас
створити подібний діалог, уявіть
собі, що ви пішли на свято,
доповніть діалект, використовуйте фрази з діалекту
, а також свої власні ідеї,
щоб ці фрази могли допомогти вам і  ми
збираємося створити діалог тут з
меншим - то слухайте це для вас
і створіть діалог, тому привіт, Джон, приємно
бачити вас,
яка буде перша фраза,
як добре пройшло ваше свято,
скажи, як би ти тільки це  було
дуже дякую, що ми відвідали будь-яке місце, куди ви
були, чи будь-яке інше  граф ліс ми
пішли до лісу добре
до лісу молодець
яка б погода була так яка
була погода була гарна та сонячна
номер чотири ах що ти там робив так
у вас таке ж чи інше зараз
п'ять нам потрібно  створіть, що ви робили ми
робили в лісі, куди ми пішли, тож тут у нас
є акція, ми пішли збирати так, збирали
гриби, збирали гриби, і ми
бачили, що грають так,
це номер шість, і ми побачили велике
озеро, молодець Вау, вам пощастило, тому що  ти
зробив, що ти побачив озеро так, так, так, у
тебе є подібний кубик, схожий на інший
, тепер давайте прочитаємо цей урок, щоб
ти був у мене все буде добре, добре, давайте
почнемо
привіт, радість, приємно бачити вас, як пройшли ваші
свята
це було чудово, дякую, ми пішли до
лісу.
О, так, яка погода була
гарна та сонячна, і що ви там робили,
ми пішли збирати гриби і побачили велике
озеро. Ого,
пощастило, ти молодець, тепер ми
змінимо троянду, а ти  читайте разом з нами, тому я
буду, скажімо, вашим ба  by ready,
привіт Джон,
приємно бачити тебе, як пройшов твій відпочинок,
це було чудово, дякую, ми пішли до
лісу. О, яка погода
була гарна та сонячна, і що ти зробив,
що
ми пішли збирати гриби, і це трохи
схоже на те, що вам пощастило  молодці, хлопці, давайте
далі, тому ви пішли у відпустку,
що ви взяли з собою, подивіться, чи подобається вам
подорожувати великий багаж великий
чемодан величезний чемодан,
то подивіться на фотографії, ви взяли
ці речі з собою чи ні та
готуйся вибирай речі, які тобі не
потрібні для свята мм-хм що
це це за книга або книги книги багато книг
багато книг мм-хм що паспорт або
документи документи м'яч м'яч
м'яч який цей розумник просто розумний
рот смартфон я думаю так телефони
смартфони добре гроші гроші готівка
і найближчі вчителі футболки так, тому
вибирайте речі, які вам не потрібні для
свята, і дайте вам п'ять секунд,
тому скажіть мені, будь ласка, що вам не потрібно
для  відпустка грошей немає паспорта ні так
давайте  допоможіть мені, що нам не потрібно для
свята
Мені потрібні всі речі о, я кажу вам, що нам також потрібен
м'яч добре без м'яча
без м'яча ви залишаєте м'яч так ви
візьмете м'яч з собою чи залишите його
вдома  так що найголовніше
проти паспорта
погоджуюсь так паспорт смартфони усний
телефон так вам потрібно зв'язати
гроші з вашими грошима на транспорт для
так як щодо одягу для їжі
одяг занадто короткий точно нам потрібно
міняти кожен день і якщо у вас є
Instagram  ви повинні робити, звичайно, вам потрібні
інші плани, книги так, звичайно,
чому б не подорожувати, якщо якщо ви любите читати
цікаві книги, вам потрібно взяти
їх з собою, тоді з собою добре, чи
б ви взяли одну книгу або три
книги в  picture Я думаю, можливо, одна
шахта, можливо, одна, так, я б хотів, якщо у
вас новий смартфон, у вас є деякі, ви
повинні мати в ньому деякі програми в телефоні,
ми називаємо їх додатками, програма
має додаток і читати з ваших
розумних років або  планшетний удар по вашому
планшету, добре зроблено, тому я хочу, щоб ви
сказали речення мені не потрібен на
свято, будь ласка, допоможіть мені
мені не потрібні книги для свята слухати
Мені не потрібен бал для свята я не
мені потрібен м'яч на свято Мені не потрібен
м'яч на свято, і ти повторюєш,
дякую,
так що ще мені потрібно більше готівки
в решті нам потрібно добре, решта
нам потрібно, тож
давай пакуємо валізу на свято,
ти  Ви робимо це завдання разом з нами, у нас є
10 предметів, ми збираємось упакувати величезну
валізу, ви створюєте свій список, і ми
збираємося створити наш список за допомогою лазера, а
потім перевіряємо, вибачте, 10 предметів, які нам
потрібно покласти 4 5  6 7 8 9 10 тож
давайте пакуємо вашу валізу що
б ви хотіли взяти для телефону
спершу я повинен взяти в свою валізу телефон,
біса, давайте почнемо f1f bone у вас
є телефон у валізі так чи ні,
перевірте  список номер два
другий кредитна картка кредитна картка добре кредитна
картка або я б сказав це так з
грошима так  якщо у вас немає кредитної картки,
ви берете готівку з грошима добре
карта карта та карта так це важливо,
тому що ви не хочете заблукати
косметика косметика косметика ваша
зубна щітка ваша зубна паста трохи крему
так і розчин дезінфікуючого засобу або так
нижня білизна  гарні ноти одяг гарне
взуття взуття скільки пар взуття
ви б взяли менше скільки б пар
взуття ви взяли б три три так
кросівки підбори та кросівки кросівки
молодець я люблю підбори підбори підбори так
високі підбори наприклад ось
це взуття  дуже високі підбори високі підбори ти
вже носиш підбори тобі він подобається
я люблю не великі підбори
я все ще їм ой я висока жінка стара
і так я вважаю, що наші
студенти були кросівками або
кросівками це зручніше так
згоден  але для подорожей так напевно для
подорожей напевно я карела парасолька
добре давайте використовувати як це парасолька
парасолька добре камера та сонцезахисні окуляри добре
камера та сонцезахисні окуляри сонцезахисні окуляри чи
є у вас  те саме у вашому списку чи інше,
що у вас, мабуть, книга чи,
можливо, м’яч чи замість взуття просто
кросівки ви можете вказати одяг,
як футболка, шорти легенди чи спортивний
костюм, подібний до цього, це залежить куди ви
подорожуєте, куди ви йдете так  на жаль, у нас
є дешеві авіарейси, і ми можемо зняти
лише сім елементів, відео добре, тому нам
потрібно позбутися чогось виключити три
елементи видалити три елементи, так добре,
що ми збираємося видалити з нашого списку, ми
видалимо камеру, тому що у мене гудок
телефон, так, так, це досить розумно,
тому немає камери, камери добре зроблено, тому що у
нас є телефон без парасольки карта карта
це добре, тому що у нас є
смартфон і ми можемо завантажити
додаток Google, щоб допомогти нам
орієнтуватися в місті  на стійці реєстрації
так, ми можемо попросити секретаря допомогти
нам з картою, так що лоукост сходить з
розуму, і вони кажуть нам, що ні, хлопці, вам
заборонено брати сім предметів, ви можете
мати лише чотири так дуже суворо добре
видалити ще один або видалити три  ще
три так добре
косметика хороша немає косметики немає етики немає
взуття немає взуття він може зробити тут він
добре я прийшов сонцезахисні окуляри і не сонцезахисні
окуляри так, ви так, але у нас є гроші,
ми купимо нові сонцезахисні окуляри і блиск,
тож давайте перевіримо, давайте  порахуй один два три
чотири добре,
але є справжній стрес, тільки одна річ,
що ти можеш взяти одну річ вибрати Я
думаю про відпустку Я не хочу
мандрівника так, але уявіть собі ту
саму ситуацію, у вас з собою всього 100 євро
і вам потрібно  для подорожі у вас
є рюкзак, і це нічого іншого, тому,
крім цих для телефону, кредитної
картки до грошей, нижню білизну та одяг, що
, на вашу думку, є найважливішим
для подорожі менше Сем, що ви думаєте, Mr.
Стів добре
закриває найближче важливіше,
ніж телефон і гроші Я знаю, що
важливіші кредитні картки телефон, і він
забуває, що для документів добре, нам потрібно
запустити гекона, у нас є фотодокументи
в нашому телефоні, або ми можемо взяти когось
із собою я  не подорожуй сам, візьми
когось із собою так, так, добре, тому ми
подорожуємо з нашою мамою, мама збирається
оновити документи natalia
нижня білизна
добре, ми видалимо нижню білизну, перш ніж деякі
закриються, деякі нижню білизну не близько
закриваються на кредитних картках, і я їду в
Австралію  тож якщо ви думаєте, що
телефон на кредитній картці так, це один
елемент, чи можемо ми об’єднати його, як один елемент, ми
додаємо так, так,
гроші на телефон, добре, тому ми будемо розумним
телефоном і трохи грошей з нами або кредитною
карткою  насправді є деякі програми,
якими ви користуєтеся своїм телефоном, і ви можете оплатити
через телефон, найкраще зв’яжіться з NA або
Plata,
тому ви просто завантажте програму та
використовуєте її так, так що я не впевнений,
що ви можете самостійно оплатити, вам потрібно
мати свій  мама твоя  тато, ми використовуємо братів і сестер,
щоб користуватися телефонами та платити
кредитною карткою, добре, так, скажімо, я хочу, щоб ти
склав речення, і ми збираємося
використовувати я беру я взяв так моя
дочка я взяв я вже
взяв так  Джепсон я багато помічаю, що я
взяв, тож ви можете просто сказати речення,
наприклад я взяв телефон так добре,
я взяв телефон і мою кредитну картку
добре, і я не взяв я не взяв
свій одяг добре черевики і  парасолька і
фотоапарат, мої прекрасні сонцезахисні окуляри, моя
косметика і карта, я беру свою карту, так
шкода, як шкода, але я хочу, щоб ви
потренувалися з реченнями давайте
використаємо два мокасини, червоний, один буде
вона вона, так вона, ми йдемо  використати половину
, не так, у неї немає гравію та зеленого,
я не маю гарного, тому у неї
є чарівний Лінкольн, який я не взяв добре,
а ти з нами, ти спочатку робиш, а потім
менший, це добре, тому вона  не взяла
косметику Браво і я не взяв свої
туфлі Браво
вона не взяла карту вона не взяла
взяв фотоапарат я не взяв сонцезахисні окуляри
вона не взяла кредитні картки я не
взяв телефон вона
взяла сюди нижню білизну я не взяв
білизну
молодець Ліза і тепер останній раз
тільки для вас, хлопці, ще одне речення
вона не взяла телефон, наприклад, і
останній я не взяв сонцезахисні окуляри, добре,
дякую, і настав час вікторини,
давайте перевіримо,
щоб ви могли швидко назвати слова,
яка перша
гондола так, чи можете ви сказати речення, яке я
маю  бачив гондолу я бачив
гондолу молодець номер два хлопці що
це за верблюд і речення я не
бачив верблюда в Україні
Браво наступний що це за
тролейбус добре речення я скористався
тролейбусом у моєму маленькому місті меніски
добре
зробив наступне що це за трактор хороший
я використовував я використовував трактор в цьому
влітку влітку добре наступний
що це за підводний човен підводний човен підводний
човен молодець я ніколи не використовував
підводний човен у своїй країні добре і
останній скутер добре я  б/у скутер
коли я був в Італії, молодці,
дуже дякую вам за це, тепер ваша домашня робота
правильний список речей, які вам потрібні
для сімейної подорожі, пам’ятайте, що ви
подорожуєте не один, ви подорожуєте зі
своєю сім’єю, так що важливі
документи, гроші чи кредитні картки  якийсь
одяг чи взуття, можливо, парасольку чи
дошку з картою, ви берете свої речі, ви краще знаєте,
що взяти з собою в
сімейну подорож, і вони чують дзвінок,
на жаль, нам потрібно припинити урок
о ні, ні, ви не хочете зберігати я  не
хочу зупинятися, будь ласка, скажи велике
спасибі за урок, до зустрічі наступного разу,
хлопці, дякую до побачення
[музика]
braum was a szostak був просто McCarty
shimoneta чоловік - allah - masha'allah
[Сміх]
[музика]
фантастика  Rasta pasta amazing II do
sabaha - Christine from at Cedars Reba
Hart oh no sleeping and absolute crew
tomato tikka do lock on every no Chico
Sakawa
або haneish noe sweet comics - with Kappa
ravika tennis - boot корабель видає
позитивну електрику для них
[Музика]
ти